I found that when I did this practice
where I looked through the lens that
everyone was suffering the world changed
once I stopped that type of narrative in
my head I realized that people were
actually much more Kinder and thoughtful
and it changed everything in terms of my
interactions now what you're about to
hear is an interview between me and
Professor Jim Doty Jim is a professor of
neurosurgery at Stanford school of
medicine and he's also the founder and
director of Stanford's Center for
compassion and altruism research and
education of which the Dalai Lama is in
fact the founding benefactor I was
walking through Stanford one day and I
had got a vision of The Dalai lava met
with him we had a 15-minute appointment
and it ended up going for an hour and a
half or so he gave the largest donation
at that time he'd ever given to a
non-tibetan cause Jim has had an
incredibly illustrious career like
starting from very very humble
beginnings then getting into medical
school he also became an entrepreneur
and through that he got ridiculously
rich and then also donated tens of
millions of dollars to philanthropic
Jose now Jim's interest these days is in
the topic of compassion and how can we
cultivate a sense of self-compassion as
well and remove that negative self-talk
that a lot of us have about ourselves
and how can we also cultivate the
feeling of compassion towards others
when you sit there and make statements I
can't it's not possible it won't happen
you're starting to encase yourself in a
prison and as the walls get higher gets
darker if you're able to understand that
and able to deal with your negative
self-talk and be kind to yourself and
realize everyone is suffering then you
have an extraordinary opportunity to
change yourself and actually change the
world
at the moment according to the YouTube
analytics 81 of you who are watching
this on YouTube have not yet hit the
Subscribe button and so if you're for
example in the now 81 of people who are
watching this on YouTube but who are not
subscribed to the channel I would love
it if you could do so and would be
awesome to get that number down to 50
and it would be cool to get like 50 50
sub non-sub ratio just just for fun when
Dan sent me a voice note saying that
you're sort of the The Compassion guy I
I I'd never come across like the science
of compassion or anything like that and
and so I'm just incredibly interested in
that because clearly
part of a good life is that feeling of
outwardness and service and selflessness
and compassion but I didn't realize
there was a whole sort of combining
Neuroscience with that well it's
interesting because uh I'm sure you've
know about mindfulness and mindfulness
was brought to the West if you will by
John Cabot said
and um
he created a mindfulness practice
uh to deal with people with chronic pain
issues primarily
and
um he's not a physician he actually I
think is PhD in molecular biology or
something I may be wrong but but he
created this program I want to do
research on it and did
and over the course of decade a few
decades
if you looked at the literature
there was essentially none and then
probably took 20 years to see this huge
uptake in the literature on how
mindfulness affects your physiology the
interesting aspect about that why I
think it's beneficial is
one part of it is if you will relax in
the body and or what we call a body
survey because what that does is with
intention you relax your muscles and a
lot of people don't appreciate that they
carry stress in their muscles right
and then the next part of it is a
breathing exercise or technique and
also when you're doing that
there are all sorts of thoughts that are
passing you buy when you're doing this
practice and for most people
especially negative self-talk if it's
going on you sort of your mind stops and
grabs that and starts trying to deal
with it and what he teaches is to just
let that pass
and so the reality is that it allows you
to be much more focused instead of being
distracted
and from a physiologic point of view
if you're not attending to this negative
self-talk
it allows you to be more present
and it helps your physiology shift from
a stress mode or engagement of your
sympathetic nervous system to engagement
of your rest and digest system so like
what is mindfulness like how how would
you how would you define it my
my uneducated understanding of it is
that really it's a series of techniques
to be more present in the moment and
devote your attention to the thing that
you're doing or your surroundings rather
than it
you've just reiterated what I've said in
your speak
okay so you're exactly right
here is the problem with it so yes it
allows you to be present because you're
not distracted by these ongoing negative
thoughts in your head the problem with
it is though that as an example if you
are a hedge fund manager
it allows you to be very focused on
potentially being very ruthless
right because you're focused on that
you're not thinking of potentially the
negative consequences you might create
for others you're not thinking about
anything else other than your goal to
maximize your return
so it can take a person especially a
type a person and make them more
ruthless
and this has nothing to do with
compassion at all either for self or
others and in fact in some instances
this is why
um these types of companies promote
people to do mindfulness because it does
one thing it shifts you over to this
engagement of your parasympathetic
nervous system which calms you
it gives you access to your executive
control functions which are impaired by
engagement of your sympathetic nervous
system so in that situation you are more
reactive and you don't have access to
information
to make better decisions okay right so
there's nothing in it explicit about
compassion for self and others right and
I've had a number of conversations with
John about this he says well let's
implicit but the fact of the matter is
that's not necessarily the case
and what I have done is to create a
technique which I think is now adopted
uh and in fact you probably don't know
this but as I was talking about
mindfulness that became the new buzzword
right now over the last few years it's
always compassion and mindfulness okay
right it gets together yes and and and I
would take some credit for uh uh making
that a reality and don't get me wrong
there are a number of other people
working in this area in the same area
but when I started looking at this at
Stanford in 2008
and I spoke to academics about you know
I'm interested in understanding the
Neuroscience of compassion and the
psychology behind it I was told that the
study of compassion from an academic
perspective was a dead end oh why uh
because many people felt that it is weak
and unlike quantitative science
psychology is qualitative science right
and and some people can dismiss that so
what I did was I gathered a group of
academics together simply to
explore this and have a discussion then
it turned into sort of a journal club
and
I was fortunate in that I had the
resources
to fund these guys and pay for some
research which always gets the attention
of academics who you know live for you
know how do I survive so and what
happened is I gathered a group of people
together and over a period of a few
years they were quite impressed not only
with literature that was being published
or had been published but work that we
had done
and in fact two of them switched their
focus to focusing on compassion
okay so it's very very powerful and I
mentioned uh a few years ago I think in
2017 maybe 2018
uh I uh was a senior editor on a book
um published by Oxford University press
called the handbook of compassion
science
and so uh which covers the whole gamut
of of this field how did you get
interested in compassion in the first
place because it seemed to me a like
if you if you're a professor of
psychology or even neurology I might
have I was okay you know recently but
like going from neurosurgery to then
compassion like what what was the
connection for you
sure
all of us are manifestations of our past
right you know we're just talking about
your background you I'm sure was were
heavily at fluids by your parents or
your environment or the people you were
around and I think that's true of
everyone
so in my case there is often an
assumption
that if you're a neurosurgeon or a
highly educated that you come from an
affluent background so that was not the
case with me and it's interesting
because especially if you're white and
you dress the part you speak the part
and you act the part then you get into
the club yeah that's just the way
and that was evident to me
um so I grew up uh in poverty my father
was an alcoholic my mother when I was
young had a stroke and uh was partially
paralyzed it was hemiplegic and um
she had a seizure disorder and she was
chronically depressed and attempted
suicide wow uh we were actually evicted
from multiple residences and as you well
know when children grow up in that type
of an environment the likelihood for
them to achieve
success in what is defined by Western
Society is quite low and that's why you
have this
measuring system called adverse
childhood experiences right where you
you know say it was there drug and
alcohol abuse uh was there mental
illness was their poverty et cetera et
cetera and the higher that number
the less likely you are going to achieve
and the more likely you're going to be
uh a drug or alcohol addict or uh
mentally ill or in poverty and so
um
at the age of 12 uh even though I was
reasonably bright I did not have either
parents who
had the ability to guide me
nor resources nor mentors
and so
I had a feeling of hopelessness and
despair for obvious reasons
and what changed was that when things
got particularly difficult at my house
I would get on my bicycle and ride as
far in as fast as way as I could
and one time I did that and I ended up
at us what we call a strip mall in the
United States I don't know dude what do
you call them here these so it's a
collection of shops shopping mall or
Shopping Center yeah yeah and so I I
ended up at one of those and and there
was a magic shop there
and
um I had been interested in Magic
um so I went in and there was a woman
there at the counter in her probably
mid-50s early 50s
and
um she greeted me with
a radiant smile
and she was you know I still remember
this very well she was a bit overweight
she was wearing a a blue moo moo do you
know what a moomoo is it's like a it's a
sheet that basically
the basically hide your curves okay but
it was very popular the the the 60s and
70s but anyway uh and she had this long
flowing gray hair and she had these
glasses on the end of her nose with you
know a chain in the back and was reading
this thick paper back and so she looked
up at me and she greeted me with this
incredible smile and uh I started asking
her some questions about magic and she
said
don't ask me any questions about magic
because this is my son's store he's
running an errand and uh uh I'm just
minding the store
but we ended up chatting and it turned
out that she was there for six weeks
during the summer and um for somebody
like me in that situation you
already appreciate at least if you have
insight and self-awareness that you're
you're being judged right by the way
you're dressed
uh uh uh and a whole sort a whole number
of other cues that people use to assess
who you are or at least who they think
you are and you know it's a shortcutting
system that
anomaly allows you to be more efficient
in your assessments right uh but it
certainly has some shortcuts but anyway
uh we began a conversation
and she was actually giving me uh
feeding me uh Chips Ahoy chocolate chip
cookies and which of course garnered my
interest as well uh but um after a while
she said to me she said you know what I
really like you and she had asked some
actually penetrating questions which I
would never typically answer for
somebody like where do you live uh what
do your parents do
and and I answered them honestly and she
said so I'm here for another six weeks
if you show up every day I'll teach you
something that I think could really help
you
and uh she didn't Define it necessarily
and uh ultimately this was a
fundamentally a mindfulness practice oh
okay so what happened is I ended up
showing up every day
and she taught me a
mindfulness practice which initially as
we were actually talking about a little
bit earlier a relaxant relaxation
technique and I had never appreciated
that I was tense all the time
and what happens when you come from an
environment like mine it's chaotic right
you never know what's going to happen
you know your mate your father may break
through the door and drunk
she may have a seizure you have to take
her to the emergency room
so you never know so as a result you're
like in a war zone all the time yeah and
you're you're sitting there trying to
figure out and you can't attend or be
present because your mind is always
trying to figure out what's going to
happen next
so the first thing she taught me was
this relaxation technique really I mean
literally going from your toes to the
top of your head to relax your muscles
then she um taught me a breathing
exercise so the standard
um techniques for mindfulness practice
and you have to remember though this was
before mindfulness was really discussed
anywhere and um
and it turned out
and I'm guessing I don't know this
actually
uh that she probably had some experience
with Eastern religious practice and you
know it's the time of the summer of love
and all of that stuff so it I'm sure it
had related to that but anyway she
taught me those two practices
and uh and I have to say as a 12 year
old I mean to be bluntly honest with you
I initially thought it was just a bunch
of BS right I've never been exposed and
you know imagine sitting in the back
room with the woman yeah in her 50s yeah
wearing the Momo thing yeah yeah yeah no
it's very bizarre but uh anyway uh I did
notice it started to have some effect I
was being more relaxed I was able not to
get lost in my negative thoughts because
when you grow up in those types of
environments you have a lot of negative
thoughts I'm not worthy I'm not good
enough you have a lot of Shame and
um and I would suggest everyone has that
it's just that degrees to which they
have that but uh I never appreciated
that
and I thought those negative thoughts
were truth
right uh
and I didn't realize that there was an
actually an evolutionary basis for it so
in our Evolution as a species
uh as an example and remember our DNA
has not changed over the last 200 000
years
uh on the Savannah in Africa as an
example if you saw the grass move you
assume there's probably a predator there
what that does is that engages your
sympathetic nervous system with all the
consequences uh you know increasing your
heart rate increasing your blood
pressure release of catecholamines
increase stress hormones Shifting the uh
blood into your skeletal muscle from
your your GI tract and your pupils
dilate et cetera et cetera and you know
you see that you run off and if you
survive if it worked and if it did it
didn't matter but anyway uh um so
we are
very
attuned to negativity because you see
that puts us at risk if we don't attend
to it the problem is that there's an
overlap between that and
negative self-talk and the negative
self-top talk sticks to you
very much so uh
as a result I did not
understand that it is a creation it's
not necessarily truth so the she made me
aware that I could change the negative
self-talk
to uh self-affirmation and positivity
and what this ultimately translates into
is what Kristen Neff and Chris German a
variety of other people uh have studied
which is self-compassion
uh and so what does that do well when
you're overwhelmed with negative
self-talk that stimulates your
sympathetic nervous system and what does
that do it has the consequence of
increasing your heart rate increasing
your blood pressure releasing
catecholamines releasing stress hormones
uh depressing your immune system uh
resulting in the release of
uh inflammatory proteins which are
associated with chronic disease States
and if you respond to the negative
self-talk obviously it has very bad
Health consequences
so if you're able to be kind to yourself
give yourself words of affirmation yeah
then that shifts you over to engagement
of your parasympathetic nervous system
so
so I I get the kind of relaxing the
muscles thing and the breathing exercise
is bad when when does the
so you know I'm I'm relaxed I'm going to
pass some parasympathetic state
where does the awareness of the
self-talk and the negative self-talk
come in and where does the sort of over
is it overriding that with positive
affirmations yeah yeah
I mean it comes in when you start so the
first step is relaxation the next step
is let's say the breathing exercise
that's one technique the very nature of
doing the breathing exercises helps
shift you over to the parasympathetic
nervous system and it also uh helps
not respond to the negative self-talk
but you can make it more powerful by
with intention giving yourself positive
affirmations and once you engage the
parasympathetic nervous system
then you look through a different lens
because the one lens of sympathetic
nervous system engagement is the fierce
State yeah right and you know this
flight fright or freeze mode well then
if you shift if you will to the love
mode which is the for this bifurcation
when you have engaged your
parasympathetic nervous system you're
looking through the lens of
lack of fear being open being generous
being thoughtful because you see you're
not afraid anymore of your survival and
you have an understanding that there are
resources for you right you're not
afraid anymore and so it changes
everything and what I mean by that is
one
when you are able to be kind to yourself
obviously as I said it shifts you into
engagement of your parasympathetic
nervous system
uh with all the associated a positive
physiological effects but also brain
effects where it engages your pleasure
and reward systems so you feel nice you
feel kind okay but it has some even more
powerful effect because when you stop
beating yourself up
then it allows you to see the world
through a different lens
because if you're negative to yourself
if you're hyper critical to yourself
then you become judgmental and
hypercritical of others around you
versus having a sense one that like you
everyone else is suffering
and two that
um
everyone is in fear of being judged
so then
you change
sort of the energy you emanate
in the world and uh and what I found for
myself was you know if you're angry and
hostile as I was as a child that does
have a relationship with your
relationships with other people right
because as humans we're very in tuned to
the emotional states of others I mean
we're highly attuned and so if you're
putting out that energy then people
respond to you not necessarily in a
positive way you know it's like I'm sure
you've probably experienced you're
walking down the street and you see
somebody and you have this sort of
judgment you've made that there's
something going on you know what now
unfortunately that can be tempered by
uh unconscious bias about race or
assessment of uh whether they could
potentially be a criminal or something
but also uh emotional state because
they're carrying this anger and
tenseness and you subconsciously are
tuned to that and I found that when I
did this practice where I was kind to
myself where I looked through the lens
that everyone was suffering then the
world changed because once I stopped
that type of narrative in my head I
realized that people were actually much
more Kinder and thoughtful and it
changed everything in terms of my
interactions but the other more
important thing in terms of my parental
interaction was I used to have a lot of
anger and hostility because my parents
weren't always there for me but what I
realized was that
they had not been given the tools
to help their own pain right because as
we talked about earlier we are products
of our past and if you've suffered been
abused had problems
and you don't know how to deal with that
and then you turn to alcohol or you get
depressed
it's not your fault right yeah so I
stopped blaming them
and changed how I looked at them
and uh and I realized
that you know they wanted to love and
give that they just didn't have the
ability but didn't that change how I
reacted to them right because it allowed
me to not have anger about that anymore
right
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by trading212. now people ask me all
the time for advice about investing
because I've made a bunch of videos
about it on the YouTube channel and my
advice for most people is generally
invest in Broad stock market index funds
which is exactly what you can do
completely for free with trading 212.
it's a great app that lets you trade
stocks and funds and ETFs and foreign
exchange if you really want to and one
of the great things about the app is
that if you're new to the world of
investing you can actually invest with
fake money you don't have to put real
money in they've got a practice mode
where you invest fake money and then it
actually tracks what the market is doing
in real time so you can see had I
invested 100 pounds into this thing what
would my return have been X weeks or X
months further down the line once you've
got some comfort with that then it's
super easy to deposit money into your
trading tube into account you can use
Apple pay like I do initially or you can
use a direct bank transfer and then once
the money is in your trading 212 account
then you can invest it in basically
whatever you want the other really cool
feature about trading 212 is their pies
feature so what you can do is you can
follow people who've created investing
pies for example someone might have a
pie where I don't know 30 of his apple
and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P 500
and you can follow people on the app and
see what pies they've created and you
can see the performance of those pies
and then you can just copy and paste a
particular pie into your own account and
so that means like let's say you've got
100 pounds to invest and you've put 50
of it into the S P 500 but you want to
be a little bit more experimental with
the other 50 pounds you could invest it
into a pie where someone else who's
generally a pro or someone in their
bedroom who just loves the markets has
already done all the homework for you
the app also lets you Auto invest which
is a great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
Ali at the checkout that will give you a
totally free share worth up to a hundred
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode all right we're just going to
take a quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is huel now
this is very exciting because I've
actually been a pain customer of huel
since 2017. I started eating Hill in my
fifth year of medical school and I've
been using heal regularly ever since
because you know I like to be productive
I've you know calendar is full with a
lot of things and often I don't have the
time or don't make the time to have a
particularly healthy breakfast or a
particularly healthy lunch and heal is
fantastic for those occasions because
it's 400 calories they've got tons and
tons of different flavors my favorite
flavor is salted caramel because for
that you get 400 calories you also get
40 grams of protein super hard to get
enough protein in my diet these days
especially with trying to get hinge and
working out cured to make sure that I
get at least those 40 grams in the 400
calories and it's got 26 different
vitamins and minerals which really helps
with the whole healthy balanced diet
thing as well now I don't use heal with
every meal I would recommend using it
with every meal but in those occasions
where you find yourself reaching for a
very unhealthy snack we're about to
order really unhealthy takeaway it's
just absolutely fantastic for being able
to have the option now I use the heel
black edition in the mornings it's very
nice I put two scoops of powder into my
little blender type thing I add water
sometimes a bit of milk and that gives
me what I need but also for lunch I like
using the huel hot and savory product
they've got which basically you add
boiling water to this container of stuff
and you can make yourself like a they've
got a really good cheese pasta type one
which is which is my favorite thing and
again also all of these are neutral
personally complete meals they're all
vegan they all have all these nutrients
and vitamins and minerals and stuff and
they're often reasonably high protein as
well and it's also ridiculously cost
effective like one of these meals is one
pound 68 for a 400 calorie meal which is
like a tenth of the price of what I
would be ordering from delivery instead
and so really fuel is a perfect
companion for a busy life where you want
to get a lot of things done and you
don't if you don't necessarily have a
lot of time to cook a healthy meal and
deal with all the prep and all the
shopping and all the cleanup then Hill
is a great addition to your life rather
than a replacement for all of the meals
in your life anyway if that stands up
your street and you want to try out heal
then if you head over to heel.com
forward slash Deep dive that URL is a
special URL which will give you a free
t-shirt and a free Shaker thing with
your first order and so yeah head over
to heel.com forward slash deep dive and
thank you so much Hill for sponsoring
this episode so you said that you so you
you're 12 years old you're doing these
breathing and relaxation exercises with
this somewhat strange woman in the back
bit of a magic shop and you said that
initially you thought it was BS so what
was it that made you come around like
yeah well look I mean to be frank with
you I mean it's a 12 year old you're not
particularly sophisticated especially
for my background but what came around
was uh uh you know I did give it the
benefit of the doubt
and they started having a fact you know
I realized I wasn't as tense I didn't
get as agitated anymore uh I wasn't
um constantly elsewhere
and I could look through a lens that was
a Kinder gentler lens and so I was much
happier oh and and you noticed those
effects like when you were young yeah
yeah so you know I mean after a few
weeks of doing these exercises even my
parents noticed a difference
well what did they say like well just
that I wasn't as
angry yeah uh
that uh I frankly I was much nicer wow
yeah so what happened next in the in the
story well so uh a couple things so one
uh you know we did this relaxing the
body if you want to talk call it taming
the mind
um
learning self-compassion and then
learning compassion so the next thing
she taught me was manifestation of
intention and
um
and again this was before we talked
about neuroplasticity yeah and I'm sure
you're aware Sports psychologists they
talk about visualizing what you're going
to do and of course uh at that time
um
that did not really exist per se but
what she said was I want you to write
down the things that you want to think
are important in your life what you want
to manifest and I did now as a 12 year
old some of them were not realistic it
was like you know I wanted to have a
Rolex one
or uh uh I want to live in a mansion or
I wanted to be a millionaire uh but the
others were you know I wanted to be a
doctor okay and the reason that was was
because when I was in fourth grade
um
a doctor came to my class and I was so
moved and impressed by him that and how
he treated me and interacted with me
that at that moment I decided to be a
doctor now you know coming from poverty
with my background saying you want to be
a doctor and becoming a doctor far
different but uh that stayed with me and
so I made this list and she would say I
want you to read the list multiple times
a day I want you to read it aloud I want
you to read it silently to yourself I
want you to visualize
each of these things occurring and how
you know you would be in that situation
and I did that and I did it very
religiously and uh uh so it made me
believe these things were possible and
so then you're in in middle school high
school in your you've got your hot set
on being a doctor correct
wow where did you go to Medical School
uh
uh at Tulane University in New Orleans
but there's an interesting story related
to that because the typical path to have
things manifest that was probably the
case in in your situation was you
studied really hard you were very good
academically and you utilizes the
resources that were available to you
well it's a bit different if you've
never had those resources right I mean
you can be bright but if you don't know
how to take tests
yeah you're not gonna succeed so and if
you even don't even have knowledge of
how to even apply to college yeah
because you don't have Role Models right
or mentors so as an example when I
applied to
um
College here's how it happened I was in
a science class
and uh there was a girl next to me
filling out an application
and I asked her what it was and she said
it's my college application I had no
idea it was time to buy to college so
um I said to her I said well where are
you going to college and she said well
I'm going to use University of
California Irvine
and uh
I said oh well that's great I said you
know I I haven't gotten my application
yet and uh uh she said uh and and she
asked me where are you going to college
I had no idea I said I'm going to use
here
so she said well I have an extra
application and that that was my process
too so I applied to one college and got
into one college
okay
because normally in the US system you
apply to like most people apply to lots
and of course yeah and so you just
happened to sit next to person someone
applying to UC Irvine that was it you
filled in the application form and you
got in yep and where were you living at
the time were you were you in California
yeah yeah uh in the high desert okay so
so that's how I ended up at college and
now the reality is
um
if you don't have the academic
background in high school
uh you don't understand how College
works and I had to leave at different
times to go home to attend to of course
challenging family situations you know
getting my father out of jail dealing
with my mother being in the hospital
so I missed a lot of class and you know
the sad thing is that
if you tell people even your friends
sometimes you know I want to do this I
have this aspiration to this instead of
saying that's fantastic go do it what do
they say well you'll never do that or
why would you even think that you could
do that right and it's unfortunate right
uh and it's oftentimes because
they don't want to see you do it because
they can't do it yeah or they don't want
to see as a competitor to them and it's
just the way human nature is
unfortunately
so anyway when it uh when it came time
to apply to med school which I was
attuned to but by this time
um
it was evident I wasn't even going to
graduate oh wow
because I had left several times right
then you know there's certain key
courses you need so
um at UC Irvine at that time you
actually had to get a letter of
recommendation from the pre-med
committee
so you had to go before them and then
they would ask a series of questions
and depending on how you answered or how
they were biased
uh that determines whether you get a
letter that says highly recommended or
uh recommended with reservation which
tells you that's not a recommendation so
um
so what happened was I went to uh
actually make this appointment
with the at the office and uh I go up
there and I said you know I'd like to
make an appointment for the interview
committee for med school and the woman
uh says man okay let me get your file
looks at it then turns to me and she
says I'm not going to give you an
appointment
oh wow and I said why and she said
it would be a waste of everyone's time
because at that time the average GPA to
get into medical school was 3.79 my
grade point average was 2.53 and I was
not going to graduate
so okay
uh
so I look at this lady yeah and I said
you know I appreciate what you're saying
but I'm not leaving here until you give
me a deployment
and I said you know if you want to call
security that's fine but I'm not leaving
so she does give me an appointment and
so it comes time for the appointment now
have you seen these pictures with Putin
at the end of a long table uh yeah
right it's like forever anyway so what
happens is I walk into this room and
there's one of these long rectangular
tables and there are three people at the
end and I'm like at the other end and uh
the guy there are two women on the other
side of the guy and then there's this
guy at the center who's clearly in
charge and you know how you walk in a
room and people are sitting with their
arms crossed which also is obviously a
very bad sign so uh I walk in there and
the guy in the center has my file and he
lifts it up and he throws it on the
table
and he says say what you have to say so
we get this over with
[Laughter]
so uh
I look at the guy and I said who gave
you the right to destroy people's dreams
I said there's not one shred of evidence
that
uh having a 4.0
uh makes you a better doctor and in fact
having simply above average intelligence
actually can make somebody fine doctor
and I said I'm not going to allow you to
objectify me into a grade because you
know nothing about me
so
I went on this diet about 50 to 20
minutes
and they ended up all cried yeah
so then um what happened is they ended
up giving me the highest letter of
recommendation wow and then what
happened is the woman the secretary was
not going to give me the appointment she
was actually in the room and
she came to me as I was you know packing
up my stuff to leave and she said why
don't you take this and I looked at it
and what it was was it was an
application
actually to a summer enrichment program
at Tulane Medical School for
socio-economically disadvantaged
students and minority students
and she said you know I think this could
really be beneficial to you but I have
to tell you the deadline has passed but
I don't think that'll apply to you
so what happened was I called the lady
up and she uh gave me a position that
summer program and again
uh uh I applied to one Medical
and they accepted me with that GPA and
without a degree my goodness yeah yeah
wow yeah so so it's not the usual
medical school not at all the usual
medical school right now let me fast
forward a little bit yeah
first of all I did find in medical
school so uh now um Tulane is in New
Orleans and that was where they were
flooding associated with Hurricane
Katrina the medical school closed for
two years they had to go to they shipped
the medical students to
um
Baylor University and actually the dean
moved there and he actually got
depressed and he resigned so
uh you know for me obviously this is
many many years afterwards I ended up
you know not only becoming a
neurosurgeon a professor at Stanford but
I also became an entrepreneur and there
may be a company you might be aware of
called accurate they make something
called the CyberKnife okay and so I
actually ended up helping develop that
technology and running the company oh
wow uh so long story short though so
they were looking for a new Dean and he
wanted an endowed chair and I don't know
if they have those here but in the U.S
that's a high academic honor but and now
chairs are endowed by somebody a
philanthropist and so I
ended up giving several million dollars
to endow the dean's chair so the
president Dean Remains the Dodie
Professor
uh and so he's the dean of the medical
school I'm On The Board of Governors and
on the University's presidential Council
and so what it shows is that none of us
have the ability
to predict
whether someone will or will not succeed
and the typical criteria which many
people use because you know grades are
artificial criteria right you say okay
you know what's the difference between
somebody having a 3.4 to 3.5 nothing
yeah
it's an artificial criteria so people
don't have to think right it's the first
cut and uh yeah there are tons of people
who are cut who shouldn't be cut because
the nature of compassion oftentimes is
the degree of suffering you've had yeah
right and you know I certainly know
individuals from
fluent backgrounds who were not nice
people at all
and and this is not to criticize people
from affluent background I'm just
stating there is a subset of people like
that and I assume probably from poor
backgrounds are nice people but my point
is that
there's no clear-cut
statement as to who those people really
are and this is why oftentimes it's much
more than just uh you know saying oh
well he had a really good GPA and that's
why he got then and I guess in a system
where that's so oversubscribed like
college admissions and medical like of
course they need these very blunt
arbitrary instruments to cut people
exactly and your 20 minute die tribe
moved people sufficiently emotionally to
put you on this career path yeah and so
this is also to say to people uh you
shouldn't
misjudge or under judge or be
hypercritical to yourself
because
when you have this negative self-talk
what it does is it takes your own agency
away and what I mean by that is when you
sit there and make statements I can't
it's not possible it won't happen you
start team to build bricks to encase
yourself in a prison and as the walls
get higher it gets darker and uh you
know the reality is once somebody
connect can connect with their own inner
power that can change everything and uh
yet if you build this prison you can't
see other possibilities so
if you're able to understand that and
able to deal with your negative
self-talk and be kind to yourself and
realize everyone is suffering then you
have an extraordinary opportunity to
change yourself and actually change the
world
okay so you're in met like what was
your experience in med school like I I
guess because your background would have
been quite unusual in med school mostly
people in med school tend to be fairly
affluent so what what was that
experience like for you well so as I
said
if you're white typically uh if you look
the part and you act the part you're
assumed to be the part
and you know the I was attuned to that
very early
uh and I typically did not share
anything about my background with people
uh and uh
and so and most of the people were as
you described they're from affluent
backgrounds and
there's a difference be between
cognitively thinking of people in
poverty or people suffering versus
actually having lived in those
situations in terms of how you're
reacting your sensitivity to that
um but no I I didn't have any uh issues
and you know I fit in and uh uh
so it wasn't a a problem and so you went
for neurosurgery residency
yes
why why are you a surgery I'm just
curious so
are you really going in in depth here
your readers are are listeners wow
um
so what happened was
I initially thought I was going to be a
family practice doctor okay because I
had this naive image that I could you
know deliver babies be a pediatrician
caring for you know young couples
heading out all the way to geriatrics
and I had the sort of naive impression I
was going to have this office with kids
and everybody running around and at
least in the United States unless you're
living in some remote part of Alaska
that's not going to happen because
you're held to the standard of the
specialist in whatever you do and
certainly in more modern times
I hate to say it but oftentimes Family
Physicians simply become referring
agents it's a specialist and you know uh
and that's not to say they're not some
brilliant ones but that's very common
and I uh first of all when I realized
what that really was I didn't want to be
that per se and but the other thing that
was probably more important was uh I had
done a rotation
and had been exposed to neurosurgeons at
least the subset I met with were very
kind nice people and encouraging but the
other part was that I had
decided my personality was more of a
surgeon
uh and uh
I wanted to do craniofacial surgery in
children
and to do that you have to do a surgery
specialty then you do a plastic surgery
Fellowship then you do a craniofacial
fellowship and uh oh and what I didn't
mention was because I didn't have the
money to pay for medical school I
accepted a scholarship from the Army
okay and so
um
they paid my way through medical school
but uh you know I had out the army time
so I was going to do general surgery
and when I started to deal with bowel
I did not like that
yeah I mean it you know I I was very
aesthetically oriented you know dealing
with people's colons and uh stuff so I
decided that wasn't for me yeah and uh
and again I was in the Army he wanted to
go as far away from the Bible yes yes
and I'd rotate on neurosurgery and the
guys were nice and so they encouraged me
to apply to Neurosurgery
now the interesting thing about that was
that
the Army at that time trained one
neurosurgeon a year in the entire Army
so it's a highly competitive uh
application and
um and I actually
decided to do it after the applications
were in because that's that's when I
wrote it on neurosurgery yeah so I what
I did was I took a month my month
vacation and actually went to Walter
Reed where they trained the neurosurgeon
and spent a month on the service
and then at the end I met with the chief
or chairman of and uh he said you know
Jimmy did a great job et cetera Etc he
said we have a three-year wait
uh and um
so I'm happy to consider you in three
years and you can go off as a general
medical officer so I looked at him I
said well that's unacceptable
that's the bullsey yeah
so what happened was uh uh uh I applied
for the program for the next year and he
like I said told me that was already
filled for three years and um
in the interval interestingly enough the
guy who was slotted for that position
was working in a uh a general infirmary
there and he was dating the nurse who
headed the neurosurgery Ward and they
had a falling out okay and I don't know
what exactly happened but she complained
to the chairman of neurosurgery and he
fired the guy before except and he got
sent off to South Korea as a general
medical officer for the rest of his time
and so then uh he called me up he said
well you know we have a senate open
the power of manifestation yeah exactly
so I took that position and there's
there you have it and so yeah
and so you trained in neurosurgery
residency but like with the Army yeah so
does that mean you rotate through Army
hospitals uh yeah well Walter Reed you
stay at Walter Reed for six years oh of
course yeah because once you yeah yeah
you're rotating all over the place yeah
and and now it's interesting because at
that time if she did your residency in
the Army you did not owe any further
time
beyond your been paid for medical school
right well if you went outside of the
army for neurosurgery residency you owed
one year for every year they supported
you oh so imagine yeah so you could have
seven years and then you owe seven years
so you're forced 14 years and by that
time you might as well retire from the
Army as a neurosurgeon so I was
fortunate in that I didn't know any time
other than that they paid three years of
medical school for me so uh uh so was it
mostly like a traumatic brain injury
that you would be dealing with like from
people in the army or Army hospitals are
kind of like normal hospitals that you
might get no they're they're all or
something yeah because you know uh the
military provides care for not only the
soldiers but for their families right
okay so you're doing all sorts yeah you
did everything and so it wasn't trauma
in fact that was probably the lowest
amount of stuff that we did right
because there's no war going on in the
United States
uh you know certainly with the Iraq War
and said they took neurosurgeons and
sent them out in the field but in
general most neurosurgeons did standard
neurosurgery were you ever sent out into
the field uh no uh I uh the only close
call if you will was there was a uh uh I
don't know if you remember this but
there was an Invasion of Grenada the
island
all right yeah and and what happened was
that there were some Americans who uh
were uh going to the medical school in
grenade oh yeah and so what happened was
they they called forth uh doctors to go
to Grenada but it was like one week yeah
and it wasn't neurosurge
but that event occurred while I was uh
uh now the interesting thing is though
as my time ended the Kuwait Iraq thing
happened and I was like literally
supposed to
I was signing out of the military right
I was done well like a week before they
reactivated everyone oh well and kept me
in the military and the thing was you
know I had already bought a home I
accepted a job
and uh you know you could imagine how
after I spent my time and I was
literally leaving the Army yeah that
they called me back now I was fortunate
and then I and knew the Surgeon General
and I called him directly and they let
me go
and it wasn't because I had any problem
doing it but I had served my time and we
were done and I you know would have been
catastrophic right I bought a house uh I
accepted a job and what am I going to do
you know because you know the difference
they pay you in the army versus Private
Practice it's 90 percent less in the
Army yeah
yeah so this episode is very kindly
brought to you by wework now this is
particularly exciting for me because I
have been a full paying customer of
wework for the last two years now I
discovered it during you know when the
pandemic was in the on the verge of
being lifted and I'd spent like the
whole year just sort of sitting in my
room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member me
and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone in my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drained just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I've got some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being in an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team members if you're
going to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've also got
various kind of after work events that
happen like happy hours and yoga and a
few other exercise type things and you
can also take in guests so often when
guests will come over to visit I'll say
hey let's pop into wework and we'll just
work from there for the whole day and
then we'll go out for dinner sometime in
the evening anyway if you're looking for
a co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 of your first booking so thank you so
much wework for sponsoring this episode
did you ever go to Grenada for no
because I ended up uh visiting that
medical school in Grenada a few years
ago like in the middle of my own like
surgery placement in med school because
my mum was teaching some of the stuff
there and she had a plus one so I had to
happen to visit St George's University
in Grenada yeah let's hang out with some
students there
um so at this point you've you're you're
fully specialized into Neurosurgery
having having stalked your Wikipedia
page like there's a bunch of stuff that
happened then like you became professor
of neurosurgery you started the
companies I'd love to fast forward to
the compassion stuff which I understand
around about 2007 yeah so at that point
were you like retiring from clinical
practice like what what did that look
like and how did you get into the
compassion stuff so
you know the nature of my story and
interaction with this woman and sort of
what I had gone through uh I always
wondered what motivates people to do
good or not
and uh what had happened was I
and periodically I've been at Stanford
since 97 on and off and and I think
tooth I had left in 2000
uh maybe 2001 to uh
maybe it was earlier I can't remember
but anyway at somewhere around that time
I started entrepreneurial Endeavor okay
and
um
as that was uh and then the.com crisis
came and everything collapsed but what
happened was then
um
I started another company and I would
intermittently work at Stanford and then
uh I used to consult for developing
Neuroscience centers of excellence
and I went down to Mississippi actually
on the Gulf Coast and uh they asked me
to set up a plan for them which I did
and it was unfortunate because here you
have this very nice Indigent Hospital
unfortunately uh and the local doctors
didn't want to work there because
there's a lot of indigent patients and
unfortunately the sad part is
you know they'll abrogate their
responsibility to care for people
for money yeah and so the people who
need them the most they won't care for
them so there was no neurosurgery there
was no neurology there's no orthopedic
surgery uh uh there is no pain
management there is no neuro ICU there's
so I laid out a four or five year plan
for them and said here's how much it's
going to cost here's what you have to do
you can't recruit doctors
and saying Oh Come cover our emergency
room I mean that's the worst recruiting
vehicle yeah I said what you have to do
is you have to create a narrative that
you're creating a center of excellence
and the call is part of it but the
overline theme is to create a very high
quality program with Specialists you
interact with who are very competent and
uh so that was the narrative that was
created because you know if you use the
come to our ER especially in Southern
Mississippi well you get you get one of
three types of people or they have all
these attributes it's either somebody
recovering from drug and alcohol abuse
it's a personality disorder or somebody
who's gone through a horrific divorce oh
okay so that's not the sort of thing
people doctors would be signing up to no
no no no this isn't like uh being in
Newport Beach Southern California
overlooking the ocean and highly
affluent in the background so anyway uh
we were able to recruit some excellent
people but the thing was though that
they wanted me to run it
because I was the inspiration for doing
it so I agreed to do it and I was there
for and I listen I talked to my wife
about this and visited six times and so
I decided to do it and then
um
you know my family moved there and about
a few weeks after this my wife says I
can't I killed him oh wow I live in
Mississippi yeah and and you know I look
I've committed to this and then
Hurricane Katrina happens
and I can't like just leave
yeah and this was after I was there
about two years uh so my wife said I'm
not living here anymore so she moved
back to California and then I continued
to work there and then what happened I
would progressively take longer and
longer breaks to go to California and
then I recruited some other people and
at the end of it you know here we have
full neurosurgery full neurology full
Orthopedics full pain management we
created neuroic with neuroflor we
created a Brain and Spine and and brain
brain injury spine stroke Rehabilitation
Center the only one certified in the
state of Mississippi actually and so it
was an incredible accomplishment to do
that and they in fact obviously wanted
me to stay but I said you know I'll be
divorced and they said well we'll offer
you
but anyway uh I I ultimately left and
and it was at that point that I decided
to go back to Stanford and they were
kind enough to offer me a position and
then so it was during this period where
I was reflecting on
you know what causes people to do good
not good and so I decided when I got
back to Stanford I was going to explore
this
so it initially started out as something
called Project Compassion yeah
and I just gathered these people
together these scientists and we started
doing some research and then uh what
happened was that obviously the results
were very positive and
um and this is will sound strange
because I'm an atheist and I was walking
through Stanford one day and I had it
got a vision of The Dalai lava and uh
and it persisted
and to the point where I couldn't get it
out of my head right and and uh I was
not a fan of or follower of the Dilemma
clearly though he's represents
compassion yeah
so and in fact my wife was a big
follower and he had been in uh at
Stanford and like doing some programs in
the local area a few years before and my
wife actually bought tickets and I
refused to go
so anyway I had this vision and I said
geez you know I need to invite the
Dilemma to Stanford and do a program on
compassion and long story short I was
able to get access to him and get an
appointment
and uh met with him and uh we had a
15-minute appointment and it ended up
going
for an hour and a half or so
and he immediately agreed to come to
Stanford uh so I just got a question on
that front what was it like meeting him
in person from accounts I've read of
this uh Michael singers book is this
says that sort of this energy that you
can just sort of feel and is like
palpable and did you get any of the that
kind of no I think that's true and and
you get a sense of unconditional love
which is all of us want right and uh and
it is very powerful and this is why so
many people love the Dalai Lama want to
have proximity to him so we had this
meeting and near the end of it
um and he speaks perfectly English but
he always has an English translator for
subtleties of the English language
idioms and things like this so at the
end of it his translator turns to me
says Jim his Holiness is so moved by
this endeavor he wants to make a
donation to your work oh and so he gave
the largest donation at that time he'd
ever given to a non-tibetan Cause
and then what happened was two other
individuals each gave a million dollars
and of course now I have the significant
amount of money
so then I met with the medical school
dean and said look I've got this man I'd
like to set up the center and it was
sort of interesting he says well what
expertise do you have in this area
uh other than intuitive uh uh and so
what he did was he pulled in the um uh
director of the Neuroscience Institute
who was a friend of mine and my chairman
of neurosurgeon they said look I'll
support this creation of the center but
um if it doesn't work out you two guys
or the guys are gonna be true
so anyway it worked out perfectly fine
and uh and so that's how the center uh
was created as a formal Center in the
school of medicine and then what
happened was I became friends with the
Dalai Lama and
um I ultimately became chairman of The
Dalai Lama foundation for a number of
years and he and I grew very close and I
spent a relatively a significant amount
of time with him and uh
yeah there you have it what is it what
does it mean to create a center
I'm sure if you've been at Cambridge
there are there's probably a center for
AI and there's a center for yeah
that's exact same like a building with
some people who are trying to research I
think yes exactly exactly yeah okay and
so you recruit the academics and the
postdocs and phds and fund research on
the Facebook yeah passion yes now I
would say since I don't have a PhD
we collaborated with a number of people
who have postdocs and stuff like that
but uh uh yeah that's how it works okay
and so that was around about 2007 so
what's been
what did you I guess find out about
compassion which ended up in the book
I'm sure yeah well I I mean basically
I've shared a lot of it just in our
conversation about its uh effects on the
brain and how uh
the brain responds to threat and how it
affects certain centers of your brain or
stimulates reward centers or things like
that and so uh you know we've published
a number of studies basically in that
domain and then
um
additionally we've done a few other
things one is we created uh
two academic lectures one for senior
investigator one for Junior Investigator
where they come and talk about their
research on compassion
we
created
um
something called conversations on
compassion and actually this is a very
selfish thing I just sit on stage with
somebody I think is interesting and
that's why I do this podcast yeah
exactly and talk about people yeah and
so you know I've had the Dalai Lama
tiknot Han uh Amma the hugging Saint uh
SRI SRI Ravi Shankar and a variety of
folks like that Eckhart Tolle uh Byron
Katie and then also other people are
interesting people
in the corporate space uh people who are
teachers in the context of certain types
of compassion practices uh scientists
Paul Ekman who studied emotion and a
whole variety of other people like that
so then we've created different training
programs
uh so as you know there's a training
program for mindfulness as I mentioned
to you though I think
it that type of training though goes
beyond that it should include
self-compassion yeah and compassion for
others so we created a eight-week
program called compassion cultivation
training of which there have been
thousands of people trained all over the
world and that's still an ongoing
program more recently we created
something called cultivating the heart
which is a similar type of eight-week
program
uh and now we have something called the
applied compassion training program
which is an 11 month long certificate
program
with people from the corporate
environment Health Care uh sort of the
Mind Body Wellness space and they spend
11 months it's all online now for
obvious reasons um and then we help them
or Mentor them in the development of a
Capstone project
uh which then they take back to their
organization and Implement and typically
we train about 500 a year from I think
60 different countries and uh so it gets
spread all over the world until with the
aim of helping people become more
compassionate towards themselves and
towards others yeah
nice
um what does a study on compassion look
like like what what is an archetypal
study that you might do at this at the
center as an example uh let's say with
compassion cultivation training we
recruit a group of people who part of
them we do the compassion cultivation
training part of them we do
a different type of training uh actually
like an improvisational words and the
others just don't do anything and then
we monitor different effects
so one is self-report
one is biological markers like cortisol
levels one is Imaging studies like
functional MRI where we look at areas of
increased metabolism and then you know
we compare the different groups and not
surprisingly compassion has some very
strong positive effects so the people
that you specifically take through the
compassion training program
presumably feel more compassionate and
self-compassionate and also the
biomarkers yeah cortisol goes down and
blood pressure goes down and stuff
exactly fmri shows what uh increase
metabolism in
um uh areas associated with reward yeah
and none of this is particularly
surprising right I mean in fact that's
why people they'll sit there and they'll
say
you know why do you need to study this
when it's intuitively obvious uh the
problem is that
if you're going to teach things
especially in a secular World they want
evidence to demonstrate it even though
intuitively you know that's the case
yeah so when I was in my third year of
med school we here we have this thing
where you can do a degree in whatever
else you want and so I did psychology
and did a lot of fmri type stuff and I I
always found that there was always that
thing and one of our essay questions was
why is fmri trying to show things that
we all know are intuitively obvious but
I was found interesting because it's
lightweight it shows that there is like
actually something here and especially
with I found whenever I dabble with or
like meditation and mindfulness or
anything vaguely resembling anything
Eastern there's always a little bit of
skepticism in me but if you know there's
some some biomarkers some fmri stuff
even with all the caveats of fmri it's
like okay cool there is something here I
can like I can switch off the skeptical
part of my brain and actually just go
all in and and take this seriously yeah
no and I I think that's
how most people feel uh uh but you the
interesting thing of course is if you
look at the classic studies in
Psychology and we're talking about their
sweet qualitative quantitative you know
50 of them you can't repeat this time so
there are some flaws uh that you have to
be aware of but uh in general if you
look at the totality of the evidence I
think there's no question that uh yeah
so okay so let's say there's someone
listening to this or or even me where
I'm like okay I'm I'm sold that like
that compassion is a is a great thing I
feel like for me personally
I don't I don't I don't think I'm a
particularly compassionate person
um
it's a dead giveaway
um I I feel like when I was in in med
school and certainly doing like clinical
communication skills and stuff I I had
friends who seemed very like genuinely
compassionate whereas for me it felt
more like it's sort of I I couldn't
quite relate to a lot of experiences
patients had especially the bad ones
because I've been lived a very
privileged life haven't really had
anything bad happen to me and so it was
a lot of kind of
uh knowing how to respond in situations
rather than genuinely feeling compassion
correct so basically you understand the
cognitive components of compassion but
not the effect of a capacity yeah so how
do I how do I become more effectively
compassionate well uh you could take the
compassion cultivation training I could
just do that online yeah or or
cultivating the hard program we have a
lot of people in England who take that
uh but I think
getting insights and doing specific
practices can help you gain more insight
and self-awareness now you know is it
going to get you to the point where
you're bleeding hard to go my God
probably not but it can more connect you
if you will with your heart yeah and
actually not only sort of cognitively
analyze and say well this is a good
thing to do and if I do it the patient
will feel better but more of you know
you want to do it because you know it
will have a positive effect on people at
a heart level two things on this first
thing so um
I've I've recently become somewhat
involved with the effective altruism
Community
um yes and that's a lot of like
within that trying to uh rationally and
cognitively evaluate what are the best
best cost effective ways to spend your
time and your money and resources and
stuff
um and again I have some friends who are
who seem very effectively
um altruistic in that you know my
sister-in-law for example will genuinely
be kept up at night at the thought of
kids dying in Africa whereas a lot of
other people including me is more like
hey I recognizing rationally that this
is a thing I recognize that I probably
should value all lives fairly similarly
and therefore okay cool I can donate
money to the against malaria Foundation
or something like that
and your question is and the question is
is there a way to feel uh presumably
this compassioned stuff and if I went if
I went through the training I'd be able
to feel that sense of altruism more
effectively rather than just cognitive I
would say so but you have to be careful
because this is the argument for
Effective altruism right you respond to
as an example you know there's a charity
advertisement shows one child suffering
you go oh my God I and versus you know
showing you know thousands of children
suffering yeah and you go gosh I can't
do anything right uh
so you have to again and we I think we
talked about biases briefly you have to
be aware of the biases that all of us
carry right here's my argument against
effective altruism and you know I know
Sam Harris is a big proponent and who's
the guy uh the philosopher yeah exactly
a couple of months ago oh really maybe
you can connect me with him but
absolutely so here's my argument
it's great for people
to do that I'm in an ideal world that
would work great but let me give you
two examples and you tell me who we save
okay wonderful okay so as you probably
are aware if we were to look at India
and or Pakistan there are a ton of
people who come from very challenging
backgrounds and for whatever reason uh
have the intellectual capability or at
least the orientation from family or
whatever that will allow them to succeed
in terms of education and ultimately by
the normal measures of success in
society then you have Africa here yeah
which is complete opposite okay so uh
and let's say we have X amount of
dollars where are we going to spend them
do you sit there and completely
disregard
the African nation or people and say
well yeah yes there are a whole variety
of reasons uh sort of the negative
aspects of colonialism the fracturing of
uh tribal culture which have destroyed
you know how they interact complete
corruption blah blah blah or should we
take this group of uh Indians who you
know nominally have performed and give
them every resource to make sure
they
do better then you could look at this
and say historically is this actually
really a manifestation of these people
are really black these people are less
dark and then there's the white people
okay then the encounter to this next is
okay we take the ending group now let's
see what's happening in America uh well
uh
instead of focusing
why don't these people focus on changing
a system that's fundamentally corrupt
and it and and is
benefits privileged people yep versus
you know looking for projects that
in many ways are just the bias of the
individual
who are funding them and I know there's
the argument well the person gives them
money and we look at it we do all this
analysis
frankly I would say a lot of that's
complete [__] and
if you have a person of the billionaire
class
uh looking at it I will assure you if he
puts his money there
and you do something that disagrees with
his natural biases
that will not be the most effective
altruistic act that you'll do does that
make sense
so is your argument that
I don't think we have the
algorithms yeah we can't quite perfectly
predict the effect of correct stuff and
therefore we shouldn't try like we're
gonna throw me approximate I mean this
is probably what will would say when I
opposed this exact question to him he
was like well to be honest most most
charitable donation is still done to
sort of the person in the street who
asks you for money so even if we can
just do it even within an order of
magnitude rough approximation say that
hey five thousand dollars would say
literally save the life of a child in
Africa versus would allow 0.1 of a
person to get through med school like
should probably save the South Africa
well but then we would as an example
first of all what's the value of a life
is giving a mosquito Nets to people in
Africa that allow them to survive
without the other resources that are
necessary to thrive as a human being is
that actually a good expenditure of
resources yeah
yeah so I I mean you see what I'm
telling or saying is there are a whole
set of biases that you have that are
making these decisions which perhaps
they're not aware of and what you're
self-serving and that's my point uh uh I
don't know the answer to that I mean why
not and so it's like as an example
people say you know there's a disaster
somewhere we need to send orthopedists
and neurosurgeons and all these people
there well frankly the [__] thing
that will save the most people is
sanitation yeah right
of those people there it's a waste of
money because you know for doing what I
do
I need an immense amount of resources
yeah right I need sub-specialists I need
an ICU I need Imaging stuff I need
equipment well that's a complete waste
of time in the face of a disaster
I would love to connect you to will I
think you and him would have a fantastic
conversation he's much more Professor
but but you see my I see your point yeah
yeah and so you know it's like saying as
an example why don't we let AI run the
world right because they theoretically
have they're not although they are but
we were simply say they're not biased
and they will make the best General
decisions to get the best result because
as an example even with imaging studies
they find underlying uh uh connections
between things that we cannot see and
then they would actually be the best
Arbiters in a I hate to say completely
unemotional way
now of course the thing is they may say
okay let's let everyone starve in Africa
and India yeah and let's put all of our
resources into the most educated
countries because that's a group of
people who ultimately are going to give
the best benefit to society
so I think on that on that point what
the effect of altruists would probably
say is that let's not worry about the
extreme cases
um let's focus on there's so much
poverty and stuff that we can solve
right now by just diverting even some of
the funds that we put towards I don't
know
things into slightly more cost effective
Charities let's actually you know like
just like we make investments and we you
know there's always some like level of
bias that hedge funds will have when
making decisions about Investments but
there it is at least an attempt at
calculating what the ROI of investment
would be let's do the same thing for
Charities and for Effective causes and
put at least some of the money there
yeah and you know I think impact invest
in all of that is fine but here's
another counter yeah that's a great
place
so the thing that would benefit the
world the most is to remove 90 of the
monies that have been uh taken from the
population into the hands of eight
families in the world or 12 families in
the world and if you redistributed those
funds to alleviate poverty to give
education to give housing uh you would
solve a huge huge number of problems in
the world now of course the problem is
and it's like looking at Davos right
here you have a group of self-interested
individuals making decisions economic
decisions about the world
and there's a wonderful quote by Tolstoy
that I'm paraphrasing it it says there
is a man on your back choking you
he acknowledges he's on your back
choking you but never does he offer to
get off your back and stop choking you
right yeah and that's what we see here
these individuals have access to
information that unlike perhaps and I'm
in the top one percent and maybe you are
as well uh
even in the face of that I can only make
five percent of my money maybe sometimes
10 maybe these are individuals who have
access to information that is allowing
them to make twenty percent thirty
percent fifty percent 100 on their money
I mean look at some of these individuals
who you know five or ten years ago was
worth a billion and today they're worth
150 billion
it's not because they're just invested
like you or I they have access to
information that allows them to make
oh
insane profits at the expense of the
average person right and and it's not
fair yeah uh and so the best thing you
could do to Be an Effective altruist is
to if you're in the billionaire class to
give 90 of your money away to
things that are actually going to change
versus I'll get five thousand dollars
here I'll get five thousand dollars
there I mean literally as an example
look at the military budget in the
United States we spend more and I I
think this is a correct number it's
something like we spend more like six
times more
then the top other or the other nine top
industrialized countries in the world on
the military right
six times more may I maybe nine times
more but it's a huge multiple of what
the other nine top industrialized
countries in the world spent on the
military if we took three days of that
budget we could give as an example free
education yeah free health care I'll
leave a poverty in the United States to
deal with the Homeless Problem yeah
absolutely yeah and I think effective
Ultras would be very full or fully on
board with that if that if that were
possible well but here you they have
this Cadre of billionaires who are
pontificating yeah let's make it happen
you see there has to be the political
will actually to uh confront these
horrible inequalities yeah that are
negatively affecting the vast majority
of humanity and until that class of
people gain self-awareness I mean tell
me
how does having a 500 foot yacht
help anybody
how does having you know 10 Homes at
each cost between 15 and 25 million that
said empty ninety percent of the time
benefit anybody
right yeah I mean these are this is
wretched excess that is is worthless and
it creates a class of entitled people
who think that's how they deserve to
live
at the expense of all of these other
people as an example it's fascinating
I'm sure you recall when we start
talking about not allowing smoking in
bars at restaurants what was the outcry
from all these people you're going to
bankrupt our business we're not going to
make any money oh my God surprisingly it
didn't affect anybody now you look at
the minimum wage there's this argument
if we raise it beyond the minimum wage
in the United States all the restaurants
are going to go bankrupt well look what
the pandemic has done nobody wants to be
paid [__] right and suddenly the wages
15 18 20 an hour and nobody's going
bankrupt or maybe some are but there are
tons of jobs available for servers who
actually get paid what they deserve so
they're all these
politically sensitive problems
that should be dealt with and not get
into this argument that could be very
difficult to pick what is the best cause
these are like things that are just
sitting there in front of you that
nobody wants to touch and it's because
as they always say when you when you
take a privileged class of people and
you take their privilege away they feel
oppressed hmm let's say someone's
listening to this uh coming back to the
the topic of compassion so one action
point I guess that someone can take away
is and we'll put links to all this stuff
in the video description in the show
notes
um take the programs that you guys have
set up on cultivating compassion
um are there any sort of things that
someone listening to this could apply to
their life like right now to cultivate
more of a sense of compassion
sure uh um
so getting you know I mentioned my med
school experience right and
people ask me geez what is your practice
for your own cultivation of compassion
so I was asked and I I don't know if you
have it in the UK uh something uh we
call it the white coats ceremony so
prior to medical school you get a white
coat you take the oath of Hippocrates
and then you have an inspirational
speaker and I was very honored because I
was that person at my med school one
year
and I wanted to impart with these
students
um
an easy way to look at how to walk in
the world okay okay
and um
it came down to a mnemonic because of
course mnemonics are very helpful for
medical students so it was 10 letters of
the alphabet
and it starts with c and ends in l
so C compassion for self and others
D recognizing the Dignity of every
person and what that is of course
oftentimes we look at people with pity
which is you looking down from a
perceived Superior position looking at
the other person in a way which is not
that they're you're equal
e is practicing equanimity
this is this idea of evenness of
temperament
uh it's
one of the things that causes suffering
is attachment to outcome or craving
right
it is wonderful to achieve and you get
this lift from you know accomplishing
something or being acknowledged for that
but the nature of that is always
transitory
it doesn't last
so if you're always attached to having
this feeling you're going to be unhappy
at the end of the day but of course the
other aspect is a down event where
you're actually suffering on some level
from some negative outcome of whatever
well it is also transitory yet people
in their mental state get into a feeling
that this is sort of permanently the way
it is with all the negative consequences
versus understanding that is transitory
itself so if you're able to appreciate
the UPS as well as the Downs because the
down experiences often give you the
greatest insight and wisdom about
yourself
and the world
and you appreciate the extremes at both
ends
but you're not lost in them as an
example I like Ferraris or Porsches and
fast cars I like living well
but I don't need them
and if they're gone tomorrow I'm
perfectly fine
okay so it's not getting lost in the
nature of how life has its ups and downs
but seeing it through the lens of
uh yes that's there and it's all okay
anyway so Equanimity f is forgiveness I
mean one of the greatest challenges is
you carry anger and hostility towards
another person and what does that do
well it negatively affects your
physiology right it it uh stimulates
your sympathetic nervous system when you
see that person when you think about
that person you have all these negative
effects going through you and it's like
somehow drinking poison and thinking
it's going to have an effect on the
other person and it doesn't so being
able to forgive and it's not to forget
it's not to protect yourself from these
types of individuals but it's not
for you don't allow them to take away
from your
uh calm nature okay so forgiveness is
very very important and then another
incredibly important thing is gratitude
the nature of you and I sitting here
today we are incredibly blessed half of
the world's population lives on two
dollars and fifty cents a day well if
you simply think about that oh my God I
am so blessed I have had such
opportunities uh and if you take the
time to write down three things a day
about what you're grateful for that in
and of itself has a huge positive effect
on your physiology
uh humility uh you know I can always
tell good doctors and the way I can tell
good doctors is they walk on the floor
they know the nurses they call them by
name they greet the people who sweep the
floors to change the bedpans
because they recognize those people are
critical to their success that they may
be if you will the head of the ship or
the captain of the ship but the ship
will sink without the input of these
other people so they are humble about
their importance okay I is having
Integrity or values that bound your
behavior and and determine how you act
and walk in the world
K is uh simply being kind which has
nothing to do with suffering
J is Justice and this is our
responsibility for those who are
vulnerable
and of course all of this is
contained by Lush
so
that was the statement I made to those
students and I think looking through the
lens of your life through that lens it
makes you realize that
you're first of all
we were talking about some of this
Success is Not an outward event
okay your happiness doesn't occur
because you've accomplished something
you determine your happiness it is an
internal event that you decide
and yet what will make you happy though
interestingly and paradoxically is when
all of your actions are not about you
they're based on being of service to
others now that's not to say that when
you give service to others
that you won't benefit you'll benefit
incredible ways but if every state
movement you make is one related to
being of service to others then that
changes everything it changes your life
it changes how you see the world you
know one of the classic things that
people say is you know I don't have the
position the power the resources to help
anybody
but the fact of the matter is if you
walk in the world simply sitting down
with a stranger and talking to somebody
who's lonely opening a door for somebody
carrying somebody's groceries buying a
poor person a meal these have a profound
profound effect on your physiology if
you look at your life in total
first of all almost everyone has had an
event
or been in a situation where
you were not able to achieve something
you dearly wanted now whether it was
reasonable to expect it or it was
something that's really necessary but
everyone has been in a position where
you've so dearly wanted something and it
was not going to happen and you know
when that happens how do you feel you
know it's like the sun's no longer
shining you no longer believe in God
[Laughter]
when somebody comes and saves you
suddenly it's uh there is a God at the
sunshine oh my God I'm so blessed thank
you so much uh and that's something that
will sit with you but the thing that
will sit with you even more and resonate
you when you think about it is when
you've been able to reach out and save
someone
unlike you know buying a car or or
some thing uh
which transcendently gives you a sense
of uh of uh happiness or Good Feeling
which of course hedonic uh happiness if
you will uh when you do something like
that that will sit with you when you
think about it give you warmth
throughout your body which is this
udemonic sense uh that's what's really
important and that will create uh a
meaningful life a purposeful life and at
the end of the day a happy life
and I would also close by saying
one of the hardest things for people
and is to know when enough is enough
right because what happens for so many
people is it's almost like they're
always competing to keep up with the
Joneses right and you can never keep up
with the Joneses and the thing is in
fact do you remember this actor
what's the name young young fat or
something he was in what flying tiger or
something
so here's a guy who's worth 750 million
dollars
and he's his he lives on a hundred
dollars a month
and he's very happy
now I'm not sure I could live a hundred
dollars about to be completely happy but
the point of the story is he knows when
enough is enough he doesn't need you
know six thirty million dollar homes he
doesn't need a massive yacht you know he
doesn't need to be with the most pretty
woman in the world although I'm sure
whoever he's with he feels that way
about but but it's the people who are
constantly trying to show off to pretend
there's something important to to give
the impression they're more important
than you uh they are not people to be
emulated I don't believe
how do you think of this balance between
ambition and like satisfaction if there
to me it's always felt a bit like their
two ends of a spectrum where on one hand
you can be very goal oriented very like
outcome driven and on the other hand you
can sort of be fully content with what
you have and actually life is good and
of course there is the idea of sort of
holding both ideas and sort of striving
for goals but at the same time being
fully content
um but it's always struck me like the
this is something I'm sort of struggling
with right now in in terms of this
business the YouTube channel the podcast
to what extent do we want to try and go
bigger like get twice as many
subscribers or twice as much revenue or
twice as much whatever versus actually
life is great right now and I just want
to make the videos that can be of
service to the world
well have you I'm sure you know this guy
what's it called the beast
he's a podcaster who gives money away oh
yeah my children well
my sense is I don't know him at all he's
not doing this for the money right and
and uh he's doing it to in some ways be
of service in his own way I I don't
think there is anything wrong with
necessarily either of these except with
the following caveats there's a
difference between
having enough
versus uh you know intentionally somehow
starving yourself to prove you have
enough right yeah where you actually say
you know I'm happy where I live I'm
happy with my family we have the
resources and I don't need to spend 90
percent of my free time chasing after
more because that's what happens right
if you're on the spectrum of I want to
do X and you have a goal then it's going
to take a lot of your time and the
choice then is and I don't know anyone
who's been that successful at oh I can
have my career I can you know travel the
world I can take care of my family
everyone's going to be happy
I don't think that's possible
necessarily are there instances where
seemingly that's case I'm sure there are
but the question has to be what is
driving you
to achieve
is it
insecurity because you want people from
an external validation perspective make
your parents happy
is that why you're doing it and if
that's why you're doing it you're never
going to be happy
is it to say I have the best podcast in
the world and look at me and I have you
know 16 million or 20 million followers
and I'm important and next year I'm
gonna have 25 million uh
then what you have to do is then you
have to analyze what stuff do I have to
do to make this podcast yeah even more
sticky yeah right and then that causes
you to compromise right because
stickiness often comes from you doing
stuff that's inauthentic
for the sole purpose of getting numbers
you know that's why you see all these uh
quote unquote influencers who'll drive a
car off a cliff and watch it you know be
destroyed or they'll blow something up
or or they'll even injure themselves uh
you know I got more viewers I got a
thousand viewers this week uh well
that's uh uh doesn't help anybody except
again you wanting to fill this void that
makes you feel that you uh uh if you get
that it'll mean something it'll validate
who you are if you're uh but if you're
saying look you know we focus on
effective altruism and talk about that
we focus on overcoming poverty you know
I get these incredible thought leaders
who give me insights and I share those
with people and that helps them in their
own lives
well that is a worthy thing to do and
that and being able to find those people
and uh Inspire other people to be
versions of their best selves then that
is a worthy thing to spend time and
energy on but it's again it's
you know I had a conversation with the
Dalai Lama one time and I said well
is it important what somebody's
intentions are
and he said
and I said if they're doing good in some
way and he said no their intentions are
not important if the effect is good he
said unless you're a Buddhist then your
intentions are really important
because of course you have Karma right
which I'm not a believer in but I simply
say that so um
and just one more statement you know
I've had the privilege and I mentioned
some of the spiritual and religious
leaders I've had the opportunity to
spend time with and you know again
while there is Dogma with every religion
at the core of these elevated
individuals is a reality that
life is about caring compassion and love
and and in some ways the expert
experiential nature
that religion has had over thousands of
years validates this truth and it is
only through science that we have had
the tools to understand how these types
of behaviors affect individuals
so in some ways the Dogma is irrelevant
it's at the core of these things that uh
Define our humanity and give us the
opportunity to be our best selves
uh yeah that's really that's really
great as as you were as you were
speaking it kind of struck me this
thing I've I've had floating around in
my mind for a while just on this topic
of striving for goals
um that
there's almost sort of two two sorts of
goals you could strive for there's the
there's like a selfish goal and there's
like a service goal a selfish goal of I
want x million subscribers
because it boosts my own ego but a
service goal of I want to help x million
people and I feel like you know this is
I guess why companies have mission
statements where even though sort of the
subtext is we generate value for our
shareholders shareholders they never say
that in the mission statement unless
it's like a hedge fund they would say we
help people think differently we help
dot it's it's a very service oriented
oriented goal and my instinct is that
there's something about that that helps
people get bought into doing doing this
thing
um compared to if it was like or the the
reason we exist is to make money for our
shareholders
and I sometimes think about this I was
having this conversation with
um well mccaskill the philosopher as
well around how there are some
there are some goals in life where you
know the satisficing goals like having
way more money doesn't make you way more
happier and so you know there's a point
of enough having way more fun doesn't
make you happier and there's a point of
enough but impacting way more people
there's no upper limit to that and so if
if that is the goal like an impact goal
a service goal that feels like a good
way of
having your cake and eating it too in
terms of your striving for something
which gives me meaning to life and
you're doing it in a way that makes you
happy and fulfilled by providing service
to others well I think that's you've
just reiterated what I've said that's my
role yeah
but I think the danger is as follows
again the thing that causes the greatest
amount of suffering is craving an
attachment
so if you're so involved in sort of
doing this thing to help others
[Music]
and you do it so much that it harms
yourself then uh and and that you know
being able to say you know I helped a
tent like effective altruism I helped 10
000 people today the ROI here is
incredible yet you know you've been up
for days at a time you're exhausted you
have no relationship with anybody that's
not a healthy thing and if you don't
make it to whatever that goal is then
you start all these self recriminations
saying you know I knew I could you know
it wasn't real I couldn't really do it I
tried but you know I wasn't good enough
and I wasn't worthy and I don't really
deserve this and I'm an imposter by
telling people that I'm trying to do
this and you beat yourself up well
that's only causing you suffering so if
you sit there and say you know my goal
is to let's say help ten thousand people
whatever it is
and you sit there and you help eight
thousand you go you know I did an
incredible job was it exactly what I
want to know but I'm okay because at the
end of the day I did an incredible job
and you know even for some of the stuff
I do do I have dreams and aspirations
about helping people
of course and a zillion times I've not
been able to do what I wanted and and uh
and I failed and I made mistakes and uh
um and it's painful for myself but I'm
still a worthy person deserving of love
right
one thing I want to talk he said
you've had like by any sort of
definitions of success like stupidly
large amounts of success
um a lot of
books I've read from people from people
who are very successful they often
lament that they didn't spend enough
time on their relationships when they
were sort of on the road to that success
I wonder if you can can speak to that at
all maybe in your life or if you were to
give advice for other people who are all
sort of aiming for Success this balance
between taking care of your personal
relationships alongside the
showing the mountain
so let me give some information that
correlates or relates to our
conversation on compassion
I'm sure you're aware of the blue zones
in the world the butt nurse work I think
it is Butner
um
so these are places in the world uh I'm
sure many of your listeners have heard
of this where you know people live
routinely over a century
and uh
why is that
and this is
substantiated by a number of studies
so one part of it which people will
claim is these are people who eat a
Mediterranean diet
uh who exercise who are at their ideal
body weight who don't drink alcohol and
there's no question that is a
significant contributor but by far far
multitudes more important is depth of
relationships and human connection that
is the secret sauce all the other stuff
can be a benefit
uh but the secret sauce of of actually
longevity is human relationships and
connecting with others and and what does
that involve it involves having
generosity
uh um
be non-judgmental
being accepting
and of course those are the fundamentals
of how to develop relationships and
you're right there are some people are
so goal or in it and in fact they have
no problem stepping on other people
to get what they want because they want
some external validation
and probably there's some degree of in
security that they want to hold that
over other people uh but you know that's
not going to create happiness or
longevity and I'm sure you know uh a
number of let's and I hate to beat up
the hedge fund business
but uh uh
you know they're people who are you know
in that uh business of making money for
the sole purpose of making money at
whatever cost uh and uh uh you know they
work ridiculously hard uh and is it
great to live in a big Penthouse and
drive sports cars and hang out with
supermodels
I suppose I'm being I've been in that
position on some level and frankly I at
the end of the day my whole life I felt
was completely empty I had tons of
external people going man dude you live
in this incredible life you know you've
got this Penthouse and you know you've
got this Ferrari and you're dating
someone so man you should be so happy
and I I was never happy in that
situation I was miserable actually and
it and to the point where I couldn't
understand because I did all of this
stuff
and I was miserable when all my friends
said would say God if I was in your
position I would be so happy right now
but again if it's all about the money or
all about the you know killing yourself
to get some external validation you're
you're going to be unhappy uh at least
you know that's been my personal
experience in my uh observation
so funny thing I wanted to ask
um have there been any books that have
had a big impact on your life that you
would recommend to me or to our
listeners
um no
the ultimate Handbook of the passion
side yeah
only the ones yeah
uh you know it's it's interesting you
say that because I get asked this
question and I never have an answer uh
because I forget them and I have the
worst memory uh you know there are
a number of books that have impacted how
I see the world some of them you know by
the Dalai Lama or people who've written
for him uh
others about sort of the religions of
the world others about uh
uh psychology and and how
we
don't have necessarily awareness of of
who we are in the world uh uh uh there's
a group of books about
um
economics and how to
look at the world from a lens of
revising the
economic realities to be a more benefit
to the people and in fact if you want I
can make a list of 10 books that you
could put in your show notes that I
think might be helpful for people but uh
you know I've certainly read a lot of
books by different spiritual and
legislators and philosophers uh
um some
all right Jim thank you so much for for
coming on the podcast it's um amazingly
generous of you to just agree to sort of
meeting a complete stranger in the
morning while you're in the UK for a few
days uh thank you so much it's been
wonderful and I know have know that
compassion science is a thing and I'll
be checking your book out and doing this
the online online resources because I'm
genuinely interested in trying to
cultivate more self-compassion and also
compassion towards others well no thanks
for having me I appreciate it and uh uh
again I I think uh
um otherwise I would just be drinking
alone in my room
I'm glad to be up seven
thank you so much yes uh no look if I
can spread my message it benefits one
person I I'm happy to do so thank you so
much uh and also for uh just to do it
another self pitch here uh um so my book
uh I should have brought it for you uh
is called into the magic shop uh
neurosurgeon's quest to discover the
mysteries of the brain and the secrets
of the heart and uh
uh it's in I think 40 languages and it's
uh International bestseller New York
Times bestseller I'm not saying this to
promote the book necessarily but I think
that for a lot of people this has
certain messages that resonate with the
questions that all of us have as human
beings amazing well uh on my YouTube
channel separately to the podcast we
often do like book reviews and book
summaries and stuff so we'll definitely
check that out and yeah
right up my street and evidence-based
stuff perfect around living a good life
yes well thank you thank you so much all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye